foreign
people we are live on the world wide web
I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report
and it's time for another Friday Round
Table
Extravaganza we've slimmed it as of a
week ago two guests instead of three so
we can focus on the erudite conversation
that is forthcoming just in moments from
now joining me today is the founder and
executive chairman of strive Asset
Management Vivek ramaswamy and president
of the Brownstone Institute Economist
Jeffrey Tucker vivec Jeffrey welcome
back to the Reuben report good to be
here
good to be on I am glad to have you guys
on because we're going to do something a
little different than I was focusing on
all week you know I was doing a lot on
uh big Tech and we're doing a lot on the
culture wars and some of this Trump
DeSantis stuff but there's a ton going
on with the economy right now most of it
not good but some of it actually is
pretty decent uh and you guys are
All-Stars in this field so uh that's why
I brought you both on and I did not know
until about uh what 35 seconds ago you
guys don't know each other so let's see
if we can uh make some magic here let's
start let's start with the big thing in
terms of the economy this week which is
this whole debt ceiling debate we do
this sort of every year or every two
years are we going to mess with the full
faith and credit of the United States
and when one side is in charge then
they're the ones fighting it and you
everyone knows the usual nonsense here
is uh Kentucky Senator Rand Paul
libertarian Rand Paul one of the guys on
my short list of people that I like in
the Senate Rand Paul uh telling
Republicans basically don't negotiate
with Biden on the debt ceiling President
Biden says he won't negotiate over
raising the debt ceiling I have news for
him he absolutely will negotiate
conservatives will not vote to raise the
debt ceiling the majority in the house
Republican majority of the house will
not vote to raise the debt ceiling
without significant budget reform the
greatest threat to our country is and
the greatest threat to our national
security is the debt one of the great
things about where we are now though is
it really doesn't take as much as you
would think to actually balance the
budget in Europe over half of the
countries balance their annual budget we
think of Europe of Germany and Sweden of
having these large governments and they
do but they're actually fiscally
responsible in the sense that they spend
what comes in we could do it in our
country if we were to have a 100 billion
dollar cut which would still have a
spending way more than we spent before
covid a hundred billion dollar cut and
free spending we would balance our
budget in just four years
all right Jeffrey I will start with you
because you are a Libertarian Economist
you would prefer I think to spend less
and save more uh that seems to be what
Rand Paul wants to do is this making
some sense and do you think the
Republicans will actually get any
concessions because we know at the end
of the day they will raise the ceiling
they always raise the ceiling
well that's the tragedy of it yeah we do
know the end of the story they won't
they won't let the risk default and
they're not going to go through 30 days
of shutdown so for you they don't mind
shutting down the U.S economy for two
years in Crescent discussion small
businesses and shutting churches and
schools for two years or you know who
cares about that probably after that
save ourselves from a virus but they're
not going to shut down the government
that's when they is screaming well but
I'm anyway his comments are music to my
ears I mean the the house has to get
really serious about this the only Power
Congress really has left more or less
kind of sorta is the power over the
purse and and if they want to enact any
reforms this is the only way to do it a
hard line and sand we will not raise
this debt ceiling into their significant
budget reforms and he's talking about
100 billion dollar cut I mean I don't
know make it make it 300 400 billion to
get rid of the income tax don't replace
it with the national sales tax and go
back to a pre-covered spending days I
mean I don't think we're suffering under
2 little government in those days so
right I mean that's a little bit of a
pipe dream of course but right I mean
the Republicans just need to just not be
intimidated and pushed around anymore by
the same old nonsense where they they
you know oh yeah shut down the
government you can't get your passport
you can't go to the Washington Monument
now now you can't go to the vet the
national park so we're suffering I mean
it's all lies and I hope that the
Republicans are have grown up and
realized what's going on here so I hope
he speaks for the party in general I'm
afraid that's not true though Vivek I've
been saying on the show for a couple
weeks that since the fight for the
leadership which McCarthy obviously
ultimately won that Republicans are
showing some teeth for the first time at
least in a long time there there is a
sense like oh we're gonna do some stuff
and and as Jeffrey's saying maybe the
one thing that they can do is related to
the purse do you sense that there really
is going to be a strong pushback on this
or is it just usual talk and that
ceiling will rise Etc I mean as far as
the prediction about the politics of it
my guess is as good as anybody's and
frankly it's not what I'm even
interested in it's about what they
actually should be doing I'm glad to see
that maybe they're interested in doing
more than just going through the motions
I liked what Jeffrey said actually is
what's the point of going through the
motions if the negotiation about a debt
ceiling or the existence of a debt
ceiling was just supposed to be a normal
routine you were supposed to ignore it's
actually supposed to catalyze an open
conversation about how we're going to
handle the national debt I think that
there are a lot of other there are a lot
of underappreciated Solutions Dave
though that I'm that I'm drawn to one is
relating to kind of an old school
statute now dating back several decades
we actually have some weird statutes on
the book in this country and I think
this could be an occasion for
Republicans to bring up things they
haven't talked about in a very long time
one is the impoundment protection act
okay my view is if you're elected
president of the United States you have
authority to actually determine whether
or not certain priorities are enforced
because you run the executive branch of
the government there's this weird statue
dating back I think to the Carter era
that says that if Congress appropriates
money a president of the United States
actually has to spend it and I think one
of the underappreciated levers I mean is
we're thinking about 2024 I know that's
been a theme you've been focused on this
week is that if you put a new president
in the White House say it's a republican
great that's just the first step but you
can't even shut down even if you're the
person who runs the executive branch in
government the way it's set up today is
even if you wanted to shut down a branch
or an administrative agency within that
government you can't do it even if
you're the guy in charge you can't fire
the very people who work for you and if
you can't fire the people who work for
you that means you work for them I think
that was a big part of the problem even
under President Trump yeah and so I
think this these are I think out of the
box ideas where Republicans can go
beyond the tug of war to say we're gonna
go upstream and fix the rules of the
road to say that this impoundment
protection nonsense you know what we're
going to empower the next elected duly
elected president of the United States
to actually run the federal government
and if he or she wants to shut it down
that's I think a rule of the road kind
of thing that we can use these moments
to sort of in a negotiation get the
Democrats won't really understand what's
happening but they can use that as
levers to weave that into this
negotiation but I don't see a generation
of Republicans today really thinking
that creatively you know does I'm glad
they're not just going through the
motions I guess it seems that way but
there's a long way to improve before we
actually have some real creativity in
this movement right I guess I guess one
thing at a time Jeffrey when you hear
the phrase shutdown I would imagine as a
Libertarian you kind of dig it right
like if you would have asked me 10 years
ago when they would talk about shutdowns
when I was more on the left oh God they
can't shut the government not the
government but now when I hear they
could shut the government down that's
what could happen I'm kind of like all
right well let's see what happens for a
couple weeks and I suspect we don't need
you people that much well hence to the
parks department right but they they
know this game pretty well what what
they do is uh they they take away from
you all the services that you actually
need government for like issuing
passports and and that sort of thing I
mean they've they've they've done this
trick many times and and they they start
torturing uh the the people and getting
people to start screaming about it you
know they're stop processing visas and
so you know they do all the things you
kind of they stop doing all the things
you uh you you want them to do but they
continue to do all the things you don't
want them to do so it's it's just it's
it's in an Old Washington parlance it's
called the Washington Monument Ploy you
know people show up to DC and they want
to go to the Washington Monument the
cops say sorry we don't have the money
to keep the lights on here you know they
did this what they offered tower in
France by the way I don't know if you
remember that they turned out the Eiffel
Tower but uh yeah so it's it's an old
it's an old game and so I'm a little
worried about that however I do think
the Republicans need to tolerate a
government shutdown and explain it as
clearly as possible to the American
people what's going on that we have to
get this government under control now
the next stage in this sort of uh
blackmailing schemes is of course the
threat of of default and now we haven't
really talked about that and hardly
anybody is talking about that I mean
there are worse things in the world than
than seeing a downgrading of U.S debt I
mean I I think that if the US government
lost some of his credit worthiness that
might not be such a terrible thing so I
I think we need to start talking about
that too in any case uh we definitely
need to take some Extreme Measures I'm
so intrigued by vivek's comment um about
personnel and agencies and and authority
and power I think he's referring to uh
to a thing I'd studied a long time which
is one of the best things to come out of
the Trump Administration right at the
end remember this executive order
concerning schedule F the idea of
reclassifying uh in fact is that someone
something about what you refer to okay
oh rhymes with exactly what I'm talking
about yeah yeah okay so this is
extremely important because and and
people need to understand that we have a
fourth branch government called the
administrative state that is really
unelected and imagines itself to be a
sort of a meta layer on top of of the
other three branches and and and Trump
had this brilliant idea with an
executive order this past two weeks
before the election uh where he was
going to he ordered the
reclassifications a vast number of
executive employees that were involved
in policy making and interpretation
wanted to reclassify them as schedule F
which would enable the president
actually to get rid of these employees
and fire them you know if if he didn't
like what they were doing that would
that would that that order was just a
brilliant achievement as far as I'm
concerned I mean like and I don't know
legislatively what can happen to
institutionalize that schedule left
thing but here's how important that that
is
um
it didn't get a lot of public attention
at the time you know when when Trump
signed the executive order but all the
sort of Insider sources like the
Washington Post and the hill and these
various things were screaming about it
this would be fundamental you know this
would change everything about everybody
we can't do this is horrible we need
these unelected bureaucrats well they
they're
that's how they run the country right I
mean this is that's exactly right I mean
this is this is where the action is it
is really I mean again we're gonna we're
gonna talk about the tug of war and the
debt ceiling but you know we have two
threats to America that come from an
overexpensive overspending federal
government one is actually just the loss
of fiscal discipline that that you know
shrinks the size of the economy over the
long run that leaves people to suffer
economically but the other is the fact
that the people who elect to run the
government aren't even the ones who are
running the government and I think that
those two things actually go together
that if you thin out the administrative
State the people who are Doling out all
of that money in the form of
entitlements and subsidies and so on not
only do you solve the economic problem
which is where an older generation of
Republicans was focused but you also
restore Democratic Integrity to the
elected government in the same Fell
Swoop and this is where the action is
and the schedule F is like one item on a
menu of many and we could spend hours
talking about this I think legislatively
there is a lot that that actually think
Republicans could lead the way in making
this a lot easier that was a clever
trick and a good one by President Trump
in the waiting days of the
administration but we don't have to be
that clever if through the front door we
get rid of these Civil Service
protections we get rid of this these
laws that say the president has to spend
money that Congress appropriates even if
the president doesn't want to we have to
give the president the ability to shut
down administrative agencies and that's
going to believe me the net effect of
that you're talking about the debt
ceiling the knock-on effects of saving
money over the long run these are just
rules of the road that prevent us from
ever getting in the position that we're
in right now bumping up at the debt
ceiling every so often but it's not even
about the money it's about actually
restoring the Integrity of
self-government itself and it's not that
these are different issues they go hand
in glove together and the only thing
that that you know if I have one
criticism of President Trump on this
front it was that he only did it in the
last two weeks this is actually what
draining the swamp is all about and part
of the reason Republicans are shy right
now to cut entitlements or whatever is
that unfortunately over the last five
years Republicans don't have the
greatest track record when it comes to
government spending themselves if they
did I think they would have more of a
solid footing on now on which to speak
confidently right now about making the
kind of reforms we need to cut the
spending well real quick one more on
this so I hate to be the Debbie Downer
here but Joe Biden clearly ain't going
to do any of the draining that you guys
would like to see and that pretty much
everyone watching this would like to see
here here's Biden's thoughts on the debt
ceiling they want to raise your gas
prices they want to cut taxes for
billionaires who pay virtually only
three percent of their income now they
want to pose a 30 percent national sales
tax on everything from food clothing
school supplies housing cars Republicans
want to work together on real solutions
and continue to grow manufacturing jobs
build the strongest economy in the world
to make sure Americans are paid a fair
wage I'm ready but I will not let anyone
use the full faith and credit of the
United States as a bargaining ship
the United States of America we pay our
debts oh we pay our debts by borrowing
more money to pay our debts Jeffrey
bring us home on this one and then we'll
move on to a second uh really critically
just to roll back slightly uh on the
schedule schedule I've point the
administrators take just so we
understand what Biden stands on this
within hours of the inauguration he
repealed Trump's executive order and
that's how important it is to him the
Democratic party at this point is the
sort of marionettes for the executive uh
State for the for what sometimes called
the Deep State and that's that's what
they depend on that's what they rely on
and by the way uh uh Biden's writer
carries ridiculous three percent the
wealthy paid three percent just
ridiculous it's just completely and true
um but apart from that his uh his his
rhetoric about the national sales tax
I'm telling you the Republicans made a
disastrous misstep and and talking about
a national sales tax I don't think that
would be a good reform The Wall Street
Journal I think very appropriately uh
denounced that idea they should I love
the idea of getting rid of the income
tax I mean that's a great idea but don't
replace it with with a European style
vat or anything close to that that's a
bad idea and all you're doing is giving
fodder to the Democrats to to continue
with their lies and nonsense
vervec just to fully bring us home on
this one you're you're doing okay I'm
guessing you're paying a little more
than three percent fair to say fair to
say
all right very good let's shift to the
second topic here so the the interest
rates are going up uh here's video of
the Federal Reserve announcing that uh
yeah they're going up 25 basis points
Federal Reserve raising by 25 basis
points to a new range of four and a half
to 475 this is the eighth straight hike
by the Federal Reserve since March up by
a quarter to four and a half to 475. the
Federal Reserve sees ongoing increases
as appropriate so that phrase that some
thought might come out remains in the
FED is still in route to a level it
costs a sufficiently restrictive level
of the funds rate one little bit of
dovish commentary here says inflation as
he somewhat however it says it Still
Remains elevated
Vivek give me uh inflation 101 here uh
for the people that that don't pay that
much attention to this stuff 25 basis
points okay it's the eighth hike in a
row why does this matter why why should
people actually care about this yeah I
mean let's just zoom out I mean at a 50
000 foot level I think we shouldn't and
the FED is a joke but we'll we'll come
back to that later just in terms of the
present of what we're talking about for
about a decade and a half following the
2008 financial crisis the Federal
Reserve pumped a lot of money into the
system they used a wide range of tools
fancy sounding tool kits to do it but
the bottom line is they pumped a lot of
money into the system they did it with
Reckless disregard to what the long run
consequences of that would be there was
a myth that somehow doing that would
graduate from the old rules of finance
and stop us from placing an inflationary
crisis turns out we do phrase you know
rampant inflation now over the last year
this was of course predictable though
they pretend like it wasn't it was of
course exacerbated by other forms of
government spending exacerbated by
shooting ourselves in the foot with
respect to energy self-sufficiency which
then has other cost drivers but the
federal reserve's actions over the last
decade and a half were a big part of it
if you ski on artificial snow for a long
time you're in trouble when the
artificial snow machine turns off so
what happens now is that because we're
facing inflation the Federal Reserve has
to hike rates we've seen this movie
before Paul volcker had to do it in the
you know in under the Reagan
Administration and otherwise but right
now we faced a little bit of a double
whammy because it's a little bit
different than volcker did it under
Reagan you at least had okay when rates
go up that cools off the economy a
little bit rains in inflation but that
was against the backdrop of reaganite
Reform like cutting taxes like
deregulating the administrative state
right now we have a double whammy
because unfortunately now the Federal
Reserve has to have its hand Force to
raise rates to fight inflation against
the backdrop of abide Administration
that doesn't have the the pro-growth
agenda that the Reagan Administration
did so I think that that's a little bit
of a double whammy which makes this a
little bit more painful potentially at
least a little bit more painful than
last time around when you had the Volker
Reagan complementary combo at least here
it's it's too too negatives pointing in
the same direction from an economic
perspective one is by the Federal
Reserve cooling the economy but the
other is the Biden administration's
policies are doing the economy no favors
at the same time so Jeffrey to that
point I think you already alluded to
this but do you think that this
Administration understands economics in
in any way that any of us might
understand economics or anyone who took
economics 101 in college before colleges
all went woke and then economics became
about race or something do you think
they know what they're doing no pal
understands the challenge
uh I think he was he felt like he was
trolled during the pandemic era to
reverse his he was already trying to
unroll these uh zero interest rates
policies before the pandemic hit and he
went along with it and flooded more
money in and went back to zero interest
rates which was a disaster by the way I
just want to say about vivek's little
Soliloquy there if you didn't catch
everything he said just rewind the tape
and listen to it again about 10 times
because in just a very short space he
summarized 1500 years of economic
history and uh all the cause and effects
related to zero interest uh that was a
disastrous policy we pursued in 2008 and
what it did is it massively subsidized
the sort of the the right side of the
yield curve and led to all sorts of uh
speculative Investments and and the
corporate oligarchy got ballooned out of
control that's when we got ESG and Dei
and you know HR departments going crazy
and uh the whole corporate sector just
got blend so the shift of Powell to try
to get uh inflation out of control to
finally having uh real interest rates
again and you know the left side of the
yield curve has has dramatically changed
the economic calculations of the whole
production structure and that's why I've
seen the other massive layoffs in all
the high-tech firms and and the and the
the the big the the former high flying
companies are having to slice off all
the foam off their their company was a
form of layoffs and we've just seen the
beginning of this and here's the thing
pal uh really has another two percentage
points of whole percentage points to go
before he can get outrun the inflation
yeah we should you know we need to
understand even though yes it seems as
if inflation is is calmed down a little
bit the December reports of the sticky
price inflation uh figures that's
excluding both food and energy we're
actually higher than ever and and
approaching six percent so we've got
interest rates at whatever whatever they
are of 4.25 or something like that we
still have to get in order to that
terminal rate has got to get ahead of
the inflation uh certainly the sticky
sticky rate before we're going to
conquer this This Disaster so we've got
a long way to go so there's still a lot
of Carnage to take place on what used to
be called the formerly the right side of
the yield curve bringing us back to
economic uh reality so we've got a long
way to go before we get this thing under
control my read on the situation is that
Powell is still ready uh to to go on
this fight but also be back is exactly
right
um the last time we tried this with
Volker at least we had a
reformist-minded Administration you know
who's working with a newly deregulated
sector in trucking and
Telecommunications and all these other
sectors that were deregulated under the
last years of the Carter Administration
so we were headed to Boom times because
we are we're freeing up the economy that
is not what's happening now so you know
we're driving ourselves into recession
and you know bringing about a greater
degrees of economic reality to control
this out of control inflation that
everybody's facing on the other hand
we're not establishing a sort of
infrastructure that's conducive to
economic growth in the future there's no
talk about dramatic tax cuts or more
deregulation so it's in a sense we're
headed to very hard Economic Times for
that reason right I mean it's bizarre
because they fundamentally don't believe
that deregulation nor tax cuts actually
help the economy so then then it kind of
doubles down on itself but uh vivec is
there maybe a political Silver Lining
here which is that we are rolling into a
presidential election just a year from
now basically a year and a half from now
is when people will vote and that the
Biden Administration can't have the
whole thing go off the rails because he
or Kamala or Gavin or somebody's going
to be running as a Democrat and you
don't want to be in a full-on recession
when that happens
I think the horses left the barn and I'm
not sure it's going to be exactly in
their control If Only They they would
wish it were it's not but I think that
there's a cultural Silver Lining that I
care more about than the the partisan
politics of the next two years of this I
agree with Jeffrey we are probably going
to be in for hard times I don't think
there's going to be a free lunch at the
end of having to hike rates to fight
inflation against the backdrop of
punitive economic policies which is at
least preserving a punitive status quo
when it comes to a regulatory straight
the state that tamps down on economic
and private sector activity
but but
I think there is a cultural opportunity
embedded in there okay sometimes tell it
to students I could say to our economy
at large hardship is not the same thing
as victimhood what does that mean is
these hard times can actually cause us
as a culture to look in the mirror and
ask ourselves who we are it is true that
the three-letter acronymized version of
capitalism from CSR to Dei to ESG to you
know CCP though that's another story
three letter acronym what's lurking
behind the scene this was the product of
excess it artificially created excess
okay monitoring from Heaven on high it's
like you know raining cocaine onto a
bunch of cocaine addicts it's not
exactly how you serve them well now the
Bell Tolls it toast for thee now is the
time to actually pay for those sins that
just may be a necessary part of not only
just an economic cycle but a cultural
cycle where I think we have an
opportunity to emerge stronger on the
other side of it to ReDiscover the
fortitude we're going to have to muster
in order to make it through the
difficult times we have I would sorry to
say through policy created for ourselves
getting what we deserve in the short run
might actually be a disciplining Force
for this country over the long run as
long as we learn the lessons from it and
as long as you know the basic fabric
doesn't break in the meantime so that's
actually what I'm focused is making sure
that basic fabric doesn't break and if
it doesn't
then I think we're going to be stronger
over the course of the next decade with
the generation that grows up under
different Norms where we actually
learned lessons that we should have
learned over the last 15 years but
didn't that's actually a perfect segue
to the next segment which is about some
possibly good news here coming out of
the tech sector which is which is sort
of counter-intuitive to everything we're
saying but we've got some info here from
CNBC the S P 500 Rose to its highest
level in five months on Thursday as
better than expected meta results
further improve sentiment around
technology shares which led the market
lower last year the broader market index
jumped 1.4 percent or its best level
since August meanwhile the tech heavy
NASDAQ Composite Advanced three percent
to its highest level since September the
gains come ahead of a trio of big Tech
results after the bell in apple Amazon
and alphabet meta surged more than 25
percent in its best day since 2013 after
reporting a fourth quarter beat on
revenue and announcing a 40 billion
dollar stock buyback that helped
investors look past losses in the
business unit overseeing the metaverse
other Mega cap Tech stocked rose on the
back of those results shares of Google
parent alphabet were up more than six
percent while Amazon jumped more than
six percent Apple shares gained more
than three percent tech stocks have
outperformed in 2023 buoyed by recent
signals of cooling inflation that
investors expect could lead to a pause
from the Federal Reserve in its
aggressive rate hiking campaign the S P
500 Information Technology sector is up
more than 14 percent this year after a
decline of more than 28 percent last
year I thought the more interesting part
of that is this situation with meta
where it seems to me nobody really wants
to go into the metaverse certainly not a
metaverse that Mark Zuckerberg is going
to lead us into because he doesn't even
seem like a human on in this world that
we're in right now an actual carbon
being and people just don't want to be
strapped into these things I know they
really want to push us there but on top
of that it doesn't seem like people are
paying that much attention to Facebook
but I guess if you do some stock buyback
things and some other weird tricks it
can be good for shareholders right
Jeffrey yeah and also huge job Cuts
right I mean we gotta we gotta save the
labor costs those are the the big costs
and a lot of these companies have cut 10
15 20 of the workforce I mean you know
when uh yeah I'll give I'll give you
guys some numbers on that in a few
minutes yeah when when Elon took over
Twitter and fired four out of five
employees and the platform became better
than ever that was a signal to the
entire corporate world
I was there last week the commissary is
very empty there's a lot of tables and
very few people yeah we gotta get we got
to get that moved over to Orlando or or
uh or or Austin or somewhere you know we
gotta we gotta get that thing out of San
Francisco but I'm not sure how long
these these gains in big Tech Are Gonna
Last you know we'll we'll see I mean
Facebook has just become a big you know
distributive advertising I guess that's
all it's ever been but but it's it's
it's also more controlled than it ever
has been I mean it's not been reformed
from its uh from the height of its
censorship day so I'm just not very
optimistic about that thing I'm glad to
see the metaverse Flop that's been
that's been fun I mean Zuckerberg
massively miscalculated on that one but
I'm not I'm not too optimistic about
about about Facebook for the long term
I'm really more interested in all these
these other alternative platforms that
are springing up all over the place that
that I hope uh uh can can replace some
of the failings of of these of these old
companies and and they're going to
explain it with Rumble yeah
rumbles uh very exciting but you know
Vivek and I were talking before the show
you know just the need to create all
sorts of new institutions you know uh
financial management places and video
distribution and think tanks and just
everything the failures of the last
three years should have really
highlighted just how much has gone wrong
in America and just the urgency to
completely rebuild I mean anybody who
has people don't understand that if they
haven't been paying attention uh you
know you asked somebody earlier that I
don't think I answered you said does the
administration believe do they
understand economics
My worry is that we have people in
charges right now that have really a
different view of what constitutes
success it may not be a Prosperity it
may not be a thriving population you
know where we ever more people share and
the riches of the good life uh a sign is
you know they you know the continued
attack on home appliances you know they
they attempt to get rid of the gas stove
and God God bless your your Governor
Dave right I mean he's happy tax-free
stoves right here in the Free State of
Florida as of this week that was so
great but it's intensifying and you know
that Port slob at the consumer product
safety commission who was put in charge
of announcing to the world that they
intended to get rid of gas stove he's
like oh I don't know that's what they
told me to say but really it is a plot I
mean it is going on and it's all part of
the huge attack on fossil fuels and
their view of our future is not the same
as our our hopes for our future they're
really Divergent with the bite
Administration we have something like
what I've called the sadistic State I
mean they they like to see us growing in
at greater degrees of poverty you know
seeing us restricted to 15 miles you
know within our cities and and uh living
off you know eating bugs which by the
way I tried some bugs in Mexico City
recently I don't I don't recommend them
they're very they taste like rancid fish
I mean it's just not that's not that's
not going to be the basis of a good diet
anyway they have a different world view
than you and I have you know and and
this is very important to understand
they they like privation punitive
policies uh they get a kick out of Cena
suffer uh when it gets too cold or
electric cars aren't not going to go as
far and that sort of delights them they
want to eliminate fossil fuels and the
sooner we understand that the the sooner
we're going to be able to be able to
find ourselves in a position to combat
it I think it's a great point because as
they always say you will own nothing and
you'll be be happy and it's like no I'd
prefer everyone to own whatever they
want and I think that it's not that the
materialism itself is the thing that
makes you happy but your chance to go
out there and get what you want but
Vivek I want to ask you something on the
products of these companies because we
could talk about okay they're six
percent more they made a little more
money or bought stock buyback or all
that but to me it seems like the product
of Facebook no longer works the product
of Amazon does work right like people
are still buying stuff on Amazon
relentlessly I try not to do it as much
as possible but I obviously I still do
as well there's a convenience factor
there for sure so that one makes sense
to me the product of Apple it's like
yeah there's a new iPhone every year but
they're not Innovative anymore the the
Apple watch no you never really see
anyone wearing it like the products that
are driving these things don't seem to
be connected to the profits in a weird
way
yeah I mean I think that that's a um you
know we could talk about that in in
generality I mean the reality is there's
a time and place for everything consumer
markets shift the culture shifts demand
shifts and the question for great
companies that are built to last is are
they able to actually out innovate what
their old product was to be able to meet
the new need and time will tell on
Facebook look I am not I'm actually
probably the first thing I've said that
I even has a slightly different opinion
than Jeff is I don't know if from a
practical standpoint this has put a fork
in the metaverse vision or not Mark
Zuckerberg is you know in the past
overspent money acquiring WhatsApp for
what people thought was was far more
money than he should have paid which
actually turned out to be one of the
most valuable properties at the company
for a long time to come so there's the
business decision component of it and
time will tell whether or not he's able
to build a metaverse or not I I as a
citizen as a side note have a separate
view on whether that is desirable for
society to dissolve the boundaries
between the online and offline World
which is what the the creation of the
metaverse calls for and today in some
sense yeah you're right Facebook doesn't
work I think Mark Zuckerberg sees that
right so he is trying to do the thing
that companies ought to do in order to
survive over the long run is they have
to out innovate what got them to where
they are to get to where they need to go
but that business question
ought not be conflated with the
normative question as to whether or not
that state of the world is even
desirable I can come out and decide as a
citizen believing that it is not I also
believe that the creation of other
Alternatives in the meantime not all
these Solutions are going to be driven
through government but plural Choice
from Tech to financial management as
Jeff said yeah I think that plurality of
choice even through the market itself
the sooner other innovators are able to
step up and offer other visions and
other other Alternatives I think the
better off we're going to be as a
culture I do think though I can't can't
resist myself here just to go back to
that discussion where you guys The
Exchange you just had I think you're
getting really close to the flame and
and I want to get us a little bit closer
about what's actually going on on this
self-defeating movement it's it's not
and I think conservatives make this
mistake sometime Dave it's not about
reading comprehension it's not about
failure of economic comprehension and I
think it's not even about failure or
even a different vision of the future I
think that was getting closer I think
it's an obsession with the past actually
and I think that it's not that they have
a different vision of what success looks
like it's that they have a different
attitude towards success itself I think
what's at the heart of this cultural
movement I'm not just talking about
government here I'm talking about across
our culture is the new attitude of
apologizing for Success itself it's not
a different vision of what success looks
like it's that success itself is the sin
and you have to self-flagellate yourself
where an equivalent of a hair shirt to
apologize for the sins of accumulated
success in era's past and so these
policies in some ways
are not about a bone-headed approach to
getting towards what we see as the right
place to go it's about instead
apologizing for the fact that we got as
far as we did and I think the best
embodiment of that is this new climate
religion which if it really was even
about the climate you wouldn't you would
have some problems with shifting oil and
gas production you talked about fossil
fuels Dave shifting oil and gas
production to places like Russia and
China that would be a problem if climate
change was your concern or you'd be in
favor of nuclear energy if you cared
about carbon emissions but the fact that
this same movement is hostile to nuclear
energy and totally apathetic towards
shifting fossil fuel production to the
east when in fact it's all about just
constraining it here in the west reveals
that what's really going on in our
culture and I think this gets right on
top of the flame is apologizing for
Success itself
and that's sort of the inner animal
spirit that's been domesticated in
America that we need to untame and it's
at the intersection of culture and
economics it's not one or the other the
two go hand in hand together well that's
exactly why you started striving for
people that didn't see my first
interview with uh with you on that we'll
put a link to it down below so that they
can see exactly how everything you're
talking about is connected you know it's
interesting also what you said about the
cultural aspect of it whether we as
people want to go to this metaverse with
Zuckerberg or not versus the company
that just has to Pivot because nobody's
paying attention to Facebook anymore
it's like man just watch Ready Player
one or read the book and then decide do
you want to follow Mark Zuckerberg into
that world and uh I think probably the
three of us have the same answer to that
one uh just a little bit more on some of
the cuts that are happening in the
industry this is from Bloomberg uh at
Twitter and Jeffrey you referenced this
the diversity equity and inclusion team
is down to just two people from 30. uh
one former employee said a Dei worker
who was let go from a popular ride share
company said that their job search has
stalled as other technology companies
assess their finances and just before
getting the acts at separate Tech Giants
this fall two Dei Specialists said
leadership had stopped setting long-term
goals for their departments entirely the
layoffs sweeping the technology industry
are gutting diversity and inclusion
departments threatening company pledges
to boost underrepresented groups in
their ranks and Leadership listings for
Dei roles were down 19 percent last year
a bigger decline than legal or general
Human Resources jobs saw according to
findings from text to which helps
companies create unbiased job ads only
software engineering and data science
jobs saw larger larger declines at 24
and 27 percent respectively uh you know
I can tell you guys having started
locals and obviously merged with Rumble
the idea that we would be sitting down
in the hiring process and I'm personally
not that involved with with the hiring
but I am involved in policy
and how we go about doing public-facing
business the idea that we would be
looking at engineers and going you're a
lesbian and you're black and you have a
lazy eye is so bananas but that's I
guess why we will build great products
and why Jeffrey as you said Elon had to
fire half the company when he bought the
when he way overpaid for a very faulty
product yeah yeah uh look at those
statistics just make me so happy you
know and there's not a lot of happiness
in the world but but but watching you
know the euthanasia of the over class
you know embedded in this in HR Dei and
ESG and all that stuff is just a source
of immense joy for me I just I I have to
say there's that like say so says you
you white guy
it's but the thing is that all these
divisions are not really about
stockholders they're not really about
company performance they're not about
profitability and it would just be nice
to see uh companies get back to what
they're supposed to be doing just
bringing value to the customers and
value to the stockholders that would be
a nice thing all this stuff happened as
Vivek said over the last 15 years when
we massively distorted production
structures with Ben bernanke's Fancy
Pants trick to get us out of the housing
crisis in 2008 it wrecked American
capitalism was We Know It direct
everything it was a huge cultural cost
and at the time I didn't really quite
understand what was about to happen
we've lived through a decade and a half
of growing nonsense that's finally being
cut down to size I hope we're just
beginning that process it's absolute
Delight to see this I mean I was looking
at a job openings right now in the the
data is too aggregated but you can see
that the job openings and and like real
work kind of stuff like Hospitality like
bringing food to people and making
drinks and cleaning up rooms and hotels
and that sort of thing like actually
doing real work or driving trucks or
delivering food those are those are
rising you know dramatic right now I
mean there's opportunities for everybody
but in the professional business service
class they've been following now for uh
for about two years now so we're
starting to see these two uh things
cross actually what this means for a
tremendous number of Highly credential
uh six-figure uh do-nothing employees
you know who wrote out the pandemic and
their pajamas at home is that they're
they're all going to be having to face
dramatic Lifestyle Changes a huge career
changes are coming uh and uh Joseph
schumpeter in 1945 said that is the most
sort of dramatic thing you could ever do
to people is to sort of downgrade their
social status that that's that's going
to happen to millions of people uh it's
happening now and it's going to continue
to happen for the next couple years
vivec you must be very conflicted about
this because on one hand you started
strive to fight Dei and fight ESG so
it's nice seeing that you know old
businesses are coming around on the
other hand no offense you have a darker
skin shade and you must want to use that
against people like us so you the
conflict must be just endless when you
wake up oh it just eats me inside what a
car what a Titanic conflict within I
would say uh it's a congressman
Anna Presley right would she say we
don't want any more Brown faces that
don't want to be a brown voice well I
don't believe that your race has
anything to do with more than your
melanin content than it does with the
content of your ideas but I will tell
you I am I'm experiencing some level of
joy in seeing the effect that you know
not only that I believe I've had and
others have had over the last year you
know strive has had on the on the
corporate economy but even the fact of
economic discipline reigning in what's
really just been a form of cultural
excess in a certain sense the shame a
lot of this actually did begin you know
we talked a lot about the Federal
Reserve policies in the back of the 2008
financial crisis which is one culture of
excess the skiing on artificial snow
problem created this entitled sense of
luxury that was actually artificial but
part of it was also even the sin dating
back to 2008 itself of bailing out the
big Banks I mean speaking of trumpeter
you know I mean creative destruction is
an important part of the cycle of
capitalism and how this is supposed to
work and he meant that in a slightly
different sense because it also laid the
groundwork for socialism in his work but
to channel the spirit of it if we hadn't
bailed out the big Banks then I think
that we wouldn't have had to feel this
apologist culture to repay the sins of
capitalist excess in the period leading
up to it but I think we can learn those
lessons now to see companies across
Silicon Valley even earlier last year a
company like Netflix doing a 180 saying
that it was you know they weren't going
to allow employees to say that there's
projects they don't want to work on
anymore they said if you don't want that
show yourself the door close the door on
your way out and we're going to put
Excellence at the top of our cultural
document but they only did it crucially
after they had a disastrous quarterly
earnings report where Revenue
subscribers profits were all down and so
I think this economic disciplining is
part of what takes a Dei Department from
40 to two I still think that that's too
too many because you know the e in Dei
Equity is fundamentally incompatible
with Excellence Excellence demands
certain forms of unequal results I'll
say that out loud even though that's
this thing you're not supposed to say
but I think that we're going to see that
come back if not organically as it
probably should have out of an
Intercultural Revival now out of
economic necessity both at a company
level be it Facebook meta be it Netflix
or at an economy-wide level so I'm
actually weirdly optimistic Dave
actually some of this hardship is going
to be good for us yeah so I want to do I
want to do one other thing with you guys
because I like this phrase cultural
recklessness uh speaking of cultural
recklessness someone at a network once
gave Stephen Colbert a job to host a
late night show uh here is Stephen
Colbert talking about Joe Biden finally
lifting the covid regulations well
eventually lifting them see tonight
breathing easy because the White House
has finally announced they plan to end
the covet Public Health Emergency in May
take that covid we beat you shove that
up your nose and rotate it five times
this is this has been a long time coming
I wish you could see the smiles on the
faces of my audience and I wish I could
too because they're still wearing masks
the end is near this is a huge moment
after all the covid we've all been
through the Delta variant uh Omicron
Omicron ba2 xbb 0.1.5
uh z95
God irony is dead comedy is dead I mean
the fact that those people are still
wearing masks and they're applauding it
and he's making a joke about them while
he's not masked just it's the perfect
snapshot of what kovid became but
Jeffrey you know what I'm gonna do here
because every time you're on I give you
credit you from day one of covid wrote a
piece I mean literally day one of covet
if not before it really hit saying that
none of this was going to work lockdowns
masks the whole freaking thing so credit
where credit is due so I hand it to you
yeah that was uh January 27th I wrote
that and I wrote it again in March 8th I
wrote it again on March 12th and I
watched everything but the watch the
whole world go dark and the three uh
how would you say hammer blows to
American Liberty in the form of
lockdowns and then and then the mask
mandates and we know now of course we
knew then that the mask don't do
anything to stop spread of a virus and
then finally the vaccine mandates the
three tests of your compliance and your
intelligence unfortunately a lot of
people failed all three a lot of people
failed at least one of those three but
uh the the really wise and intelligent
among us and you're among them uh you
know passed all three tests so but it's
interesting that he's still got his
audience masked it occurred to me
watching that when I first I first saw
that clip I thought wow these people
just continue to engage in these
mythological superstitious religions
what's wrong with them but then he
realized something
this is a way that he can assure that
everybody in his audience is going to
laugh at his jokes there's anybody who
would sit there in a mass
this kind of got to be an idiot right so
it's self-select filtering the
population of his audience to make sure
that people think he's funny
I mean Vivek isn't it just extraordinary
watching that at this point and that
people still I mean it goes to the group
think it goes to the the failure of of
just all of us I would put all of us
myself included that we all should have
screamed more I was pretty good after
two weeks to flatten the curve I pretty
much saw it right then as I said Jeffrey
got it on day one but that we all should
have been just absolutely enraged and I
think what what scares me now is that
there's a whole bunch of people that are
going to gladly welcome it when it comes
for climate lockdowns or covid 6 or or
monkey pox or whatever's next or climate
change right climate catastrophe because
that is definitely the one that is
coming with the same religion rearing
his head under under new Avatar so look
I mean this shows up in in many
different forms even as it relates to
covid just to close the loop on that one
I mean it's not just the masks in in you
know his audience or whatever late night
you know Novak Djokovic I'm a big tennis
fan so this is a little personal to me
Novak Joker just won the Australian Open
yep quite possibly arguably if not
already the greatest tennis player of
all time will for the second consecutive
year at least as of now not be allowed
to enter the United States to play the
next tournaments of like Indian Wells
and Miami top tournaments that are
coming up after he won the Australian
Open it's just and wasn't allowed to
play in the Australian Open the year
before because he wasn't vaccinated but
every every year classes I mean even if
you just are our Lock Stock and Barrel
bought into the religion it doesn't make
sense on its own terms now for a vaccine
that's how outdated relative to even not
only what the case numbers are but where
the virus is I'm almost dignifying it by
even talking about it and getting into
the detail of it because it's just it's
a religion at its core
and I just think the interesting thing
to think about whether it's covid
whether it's climate whatever comes next
and you're right to ask that question
because you know this ship is is finally
has finally you know moved past the
Horizon where hopefully we're not going
to see this one anymore it's just going
to be a new one that shows up
what is it within each of us right we
spend a lot of time myself included
complaining about the collusion of
private power and state power to do what
neither one could do on its own to
create this new authoritarian form of
centralization and we've seen it and
we're going to continue to see it but it
does take two to tango and I think that
the question for us to also start with
at the bottom up level is look in the
mirror and ask ourselves within each of
us what side is it of Our Own Heart and
Soul that wants to bow down to this
Authority this is an ancient human
instinct I mean it's why the Israelites
wanted to go back to be ruled by Pharaoh
when they were lost in the desert I mean
this is innate stuff in humanity and in
each of us and I think that though it's
easy for us to point to the you know I
think a lot of this is top down a lot of
this is cynical a lot of this is
authoritarian and power centralizing but
it's not just that I think that it only
works insofar as each of us within
submits to the inner slave within each
of of us where we're told to shut up sit
down and do as we're told but we tell
ourselves to shut up sit down and do as
we're told sometimes too maybe not
Jeffrey because he sounds like he was
all over it since day one but you know
I've felt very much alone and and we had
a hard time finding each other it turns
out to be rather deliberate now and
looking back at it but your comments do
remind me of this book by Matthias Des
met which I haven't read but I've seen
so many wonderful excerpts of it I think
it's called psychology of
totalitarianism or something we really
do need to come to terms with this and
on the travel restrictions in particular
it's not just Djokovic I have a fellow
of Brownstone Institute in Canada who
cannot come for a fellow's retreat I
have in two weeks because she refused
the the vaccine and there are millions
of people all over the world that are
profoundly affected by this in the
United States uh unvaccinated foreign
Nationals cannot come to visit to see
the Statue of Liberty that's what we
have going on in this country right now
not enough people care about it it's an
outrage religious thing I continue to
run articles about it but I think I'm
one of the only venues that's that's and
it's not clear that when the emergency
ends in May that if that was going to be
lifted or not this is an outrage that
we're doing they might as well not see
it because the Statue of Liberty in this
environment is just a hollowed out husk
of itself anyway right what's the point
of coming to see a symbol if the place
to which you come doesn't even live what
it's supposed to symbolize so in a
certain sense there's a poetic
tragically fitting Poetic Justice to the
whole thing but you know I think that it
starts from looking within each of us
two as Citizens because you know Dave I
appreciate your vulnerability and
openness and sharing and sharing you
know your own perspective on you know
covid but I just think that I wish more
people do what you did
I think one of the things that they
really prayed on is sort of the blase
attitude that most people just have
towards life and maybe that's just
because of video games and porn and
drugs and whatever social media people
just people just go and go and go and
then there was like an excitement for a
couple weeks and people were like oh I'm
locked in my house it at least it's
different something something may not
affect yeah something to that effect
listen you guys this was an absolutely
fantastic panel I definitely want to
have you guys on together I'll link to
both the Jeffrey we're going to link to
your early covid video because it's just
phenomenal you nailed everything uh
Vivek we're gonna uh we'll link to your
original interview with me which was all
about strive and and some of the
solutions to a lot of what we talked
about here today I appreciate you guys
have a great weekend and we are going to
do a post game show on locals
in about 42 seconds so stay with me
everybody
[Music]
foreign